No one thing I noticed uh finished past
weekend yeah why people have taken over
this movement I went to two marches go
[ __ ] me how they taught Ella I know I
would say there was five black people
for every hundred white people there son
I was shocked and this was in Flatbush
Brooklyn sign I was in Santa Barbara
okay
no white is [ __ ] but they had a had they
had a March going to it and so I took my
girl's family and [ __ ] I really tried to
impress not so T I love that impresses
them I mean it's like it shows you I'm
with it yeah I mean her dad was fresh
out of surgery I'm like making him
hobble down the [ __ ] Street to go to
this report and but I just wanted to
check it out because I was like there's
no black people is Hannah barber like
very few right yeah and there was a few
people there and it was cool everybody
support and everything like that by
start to look around at the people at
the March and I was like hmm
salt matte white [ __ ] with dreads
hippy doubt Burning Man [ __ ] and write a
few like [ __ ] and [ __ ] and one just
had a sign this chick with titties and
everything I'm a man I was like that got
nothing to do with what's going on here
right and I go oh [ __ ] this has become
the outcast like anybody who's an Alkesh
to bite against the system that they
believe has oppressed them is now
supporting this thing and they're saying
it in terms of black lives matter but
pardon me is kind of like they just want
to tear down the system that made them
feel like [ __ ] we're inferior or not
part or something and I wonder if it's
gonna start to get co-opted because as I
see more of these things they're looking
fun and I'm not saying you shouldn't
have fun at a protest but you shouldn't
but I think people should have never
cupid shuffle at that protest that's one
that was the tipping point that's and
white people are like yo son be honest
right if you're at a protest
and you're the powers-that-be and you
see them screaming and angry and
defacing public property and doing that
kind of [ __ ] you're like yo we got to do
something hmm
if you see [ __ ] dancing and
singing and yg dropping new music that's
a block party it's a block parties here
like oh they're good they just want to
kick it they're gonna be good
everything's fine
I really don't know if it helps the
severity and seriousness of the movement
if everybody's so joyous can I be honest
though that's why if you're just doing a
peaceful protest without like any kind
of economic sanction of any kind
informal to formal yeah nobody I don't
think is gonna listen you're just
hanging out on a percent agreement gives
a [ __ ]
women's March yeah yeah what that change
I can't name like a single piece of
legislative difference like what would
it change I would say just the collector
if some of these women the careers they
wanted what oh yeah yeah but I would
just say like behavior has changed a
little bit yeah I don't know if that was
from the March but I understand but it
is interesting that you saw that and I
wonder if that affects it like I think
the me to movement a lot of people were
like oh [ __ ] yeah maybe we could be a
little better but the March I don't
think I don't want to talk about that
meets you should I'm just saying I'm
just saying the March I don't think did
and he's like I think the marsh where
people were like oh yo these [ __ ] are
walking for this they're serious oh that
sign really changed my perspective yeah
let's talk about this this black lives
matter thing okay so you're in there
yeah and then you feel like what
happened like this it was it still black
lives matter we're like this is a party
people just need to know something the
message still on point but there is fun
being had yeah it's like you know the
chants the rhyming it's like yeah it's
it is fun yeah and sometimes somebody
won't pass with like a really big ass
speaker and just be playing music and
[ __ ] like that but at the same time
there's still for every for every two
songs of fun then there's chance to [ __ ]
the police and all that type of stuff
going on as well so it's like the
message is still on point it's still
black lives matter Barry
so but yeah but now I feel like what's
and this is my concern right like I'm
concerned that what happens is when you
get power and you get influence you
start to ask for more and more [ __ ]
right and I fear that the focus will go
away from the thing that they want and
then the goals will start to get
unrealistic and then nothing will be
achieved you know I think the first
thing that we saw was when Chavan got
his murder charge upgraded to murder too
so murder 3 - murder - anybody listening
from another country doesn't understand
it I'm sure you guys have similar rules
where there's different degrees of
murder al murder 3 is what that's almost
like unintentional yeah unintentional
it's very close to manslaughter yeah
just a little bit like it's like not a
mistake
yeah like manslaughter you truly didn't
mean to kill the person yeah this is
you're doing an action to them that they
ended up dying yeah well like you know
this action could you kill the person
and you continue doing now murder 2 you
get closer to the idea like you want
I think murder 2 is you want to kill
them and then murder 1 is premeditated
murder so 2 is intent with no
premeditation and right as premeditation
so the concern I have is they up the
charge and then the masses were like
yeah stay up the charge but I'm like yo
hold up if you chart if you go in there
trying to get Murder two you can't
settle for murder 3 you're not gonna
settle for murder 3 so you might not get
anything so here's a strategy because I
was looking that up but I was worried
about that as well okay
added to it and so it's better to go in
with a bunch of charges better okay
because then you're more likely for the
nobility all right we're not gonna
charge them with the hardest [ __ ] but
we'll give them one of the little ones
okay and so if the biggest one was the
murder three yep he might have walked on
that one but now that Murder two is the
biggest one now it's like most likely
divorce settlement bo the [ __ ] goes on
a half and you go ten percent you are
and that's my same theory on these
marches cuz I know you disagree
divorce report that's not how it goes oh
yeah 10% okay
yes gender is I don't work like that
10% I'm not saying what's right and
wrong I'm saying what happens you think
dudes out here getting divorced and
giving up 10% how much do you know about
half yo Nick come on bro that's usually
more than us [ __ ] working for the
government
there's no coincidence that Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez was rich he was a give up
65% single last yeah once you get a man
that could give you a half a single
[ __ ] in Congress like we what happier
tax money get a rich man
[Applause]